ich glaube bei der AFD steht auch so
eine riesen Ball rum auf ein paar Tage
mit Zigeunersoße ohne Schnitzel die Soße
pure ne das ist einfach so reingreifen kann
oh nimmt es mir nicht geht es mir ich will
es haben ich lasse ich mir nicht nehmen und
so ganz alte Tafel wird ganz alter Schrift
so sütter die Negerkuss steht da dran ich
lass mir doch das Maul nicht verbieten
hä Rede ist meine Idee meine Identität
gesagt oder ja und was unsere Identität nein
du willst immer so klar ne das erinnert mich
immer besser für dich ich liebe mache mir
zum Löffel ich glaube wir rum das merke ich
ja besser ich sag dir was ich bin gerade
in Dresden tätig am Start Schauspieler ne
und da hat neulich der björn höcke hat
er geredet da ist übrigens Björn höcke
ich dachte das Landolf so und der hatte geredet
über nationale Identität das wollte ich anschauen
ne weil ich mich auch verwirrt da habe ich da
weiter vorne und da war der Jeanshose ne so ganz
engen Jeanshose 72 der so alt wie ich so ganz
muskulöse und das von romantischer Waldläufer
der spricht dazu mir über nationale Identität ich
schau nur auf diese Hose sagt ich konnte gar nicht
ich habe gar nichts auf diese Hose gestartet
und die Hose die Baumwolle kommt aus Kasachstan
und der das Indigo aus der Türkei dann wird es in
China zusammengemietet mit irgendwelchen Knöpfen
aus Italien da kommst nach Frankreich die Hose und
wird irgendwie gestorben warsch mit Bimsstein aus
Griechenland und dann kommt erst nach Deutschland
und da stehen drauf so ein Pepper made in Germany
und dieser pepperstatter vor mir und rede über
Nation hat gesagt diese Hose der hat eine Hose
an jetzt schaut doch mal die Hose dann haben
sie mich abgeführt nicht verstanden [Applaus]
Hitler und die Nazis sind nur ein Vogelschiss
Mädchen und alimentierte messermänner und einzige
Tage nichtse auch für die brandenburgische AFD ist
ja oder Fontan identitätsstiften zwischen vielen
von Fontanes Gedanken und den Ideen der AFD gibt
es große Überschneidungen so seine Heimatliebe
unser konservativer Werte kann und vielleicht
werden heute er afd-mitglied nein [Musik]
gebe Ihnen mein Ehrenwort
die Rente ist sicher meine Familie
verfasste Dissertation ist kein Plagiat
have sexual relations ich tue das weil
ich ein absolut reines Gewissen habe
Kokain zu mir genommen die
Analyse die ich habe machen lassen
[Gelächter]